[Music]
so i was watching a show that i just
binged uh because i loved season one of
it season two came out
love is blind
love is blind yes it's on netflix it's
on netflix so you so i told you reality
show on netflix yeah so they start
talking about money that's why we're
gonna talk about it here in a second but
i mentioned it to james and and dave i
was like hey if we want to do a fun
segment this is a great one because they
were literally talking about like 401ks
and all this and it's funny and
cringe-worthy all of it
he's like it's blind i don't know are
they blind i don't get it and i was like
no how does this how does this work
what is the premise of this deep show
are you ready you're gonna die you're
absolutely gonna die so they have men on
one side women on the other and they
have these things called pods
so there's these rooms that they can
enter in at the opposite ends but
there's a wall in between so you can't
see them but you can talk it's like a
paper thin wall so you can talk to them
but you can't see them
and so the men and women will switch
through different pods to meet different
people
uh and start these conversations and
then naturally of course you kind of
have chemistry with one over the other
so you meet them back in the pod to talk
more so you're like never having seen
them yep so you have like four days so
this is kind of like a rat and a wheel
rat riding a maze so then a series of
rats in the middle so then you fall in
love
just through the paper wall through the
paper wall
and i'm gonna and i know you were i know
you were just stay with me it gets worse
get ready so then if you propose
then you finally get to see each other
so you propose
the person accepts or doesn't accept
then you then they meet each other okay
so then they see each other for the
first time so whoever
does the proposal then they take them to
mexico for like another two to three
days and then from there if the
relationship continues to go then they
take them to chicago and they live in an
apartment together for like three days
because then the wedding is that
saturday so everything's within like
two and a half weeks like it's really
fast
this is great entertainment so the clip
we're going to cringe i know i know
you're gonna die i know but it's so this
is so dysfunctional it's so good it's
not good at all so there's nothing
chicago is not good
getting married to someone you've never
met is not good no they've met they just
haven't seen each other love is blind so
anyways
the clip that came up
were of two of the people and they're in
their apartment in chicago and they
start talking so they're about to get
married yes yes so let's so they're in
love for
35 seconds now through the paper wall
hundred percent
god yeah so shane i know and you are you
actually spent your time it gets you you
can't you know hours of your life you
will never get back on this crap i know
but be ashamed
but you start to like know the people
know the backstory they meet the
families and you're just these are not
people
you're just committed you're committed
you don't know people that would do
stuff like that you're committed so
anyway you ought to be committed here it
is
oh my gosh catherine if anyone's
listening that was on love is blind i am
with you dave is not but you're right
i'm not i'm so nervous i haven't i i
never heard of it until just now i know
i that was the best part i was like i'm
not gonna tell you until on air so you
can just trash it you know die in your
seat
okay so here's the clip of them talking
are you are you prepared for this i'm
ready i'm ready i'm ready here we go i
feel like we definitely need a
two-bedroom but i think we should think
about buying for first place
only because like i'm like prepared for
it financially so i mean yeah i need to
sit down and like look at our finances
though because i don't do that
at all really which is kind of probably
not smart i mean do you spend a lot on
going out and like clothes or things
like that where i spend my money is on
food
oh my god over like probably two
thousand dollars a month
okay shane we like can't do that anymore
we need to be like really aligned on
like numbers and like what are our
financial milestones and like how much
do we want in our 401k
i don't really believe in 401ks what i
don't believe in forward what do you
mean you don't believe in it i take
risks a lot with that kind of stuff
so
i guess that's where we are a little
different like i take like like taking
risks we can't just live a normal life
where we just buy a house and put money
in our 401ks
that's just just
we can't live a normal life and just buy
a house and put money in and we have
this we have we're airing this to 20
million people on our show why
i know because i just laugh at this
place
i'm not laughing at him what i'm just
saying here is the reality here's the
reality
and the get rich quick idea so what i
was hearing from him as i was watching
this girl i thought oh no shane no he
says he doesn't believe in 401ks
but there's the reality of the get rich
quick right
everything that we're that we've talked
about i feel like recently on even the
building wealth event all of it is like
there is this need and this desire and
this excitement for
a percentage of the population
that they're like i don't want to just
be safe i want to go and do something
crazy because if i do something crazy
and i take risks it's going to pay off
and the danger in that no it's dangerous
i like to ascribe when someone's making
that argument i like to ascribe
25 years more emotional maturity to that
person than that guy has
that guy's like four years old
i mean that he's just i spend two
thousand dollars on food and i don't
believe in saving money i'm just gonna
get he's he's really not a bright young
man but well shane i mean not in the
financial space maybe not the romantic
space either
anyways i saw and i thought i was just
thinking of her dad her dad is watching
this going well they didn't get married
they got to the altar and she said no
she said no so probably for a lot of
reasons but
but it's uh yeah but anyways i saw that
and i thought man that's so here's the
thing
there's a couple things we talk about
this in building wealth that drive
people to get rich quick
okay
uh one is fear and one is greed
yes okay and in shane's case it's um i
think it probably falls in i i'm
guessing here but it sounds like it
falls in the greeting right because he
wants something for nothing yes
he doesn't want to pay a price to win no
discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
you live like no one else later you get
to live and give like no one else
children do what feels good adults
devise a plan and follow it one
definition of maturity is learning to
delay pleasure
and that's why my brain is melting down
watching this
good-looking young man
who has the emotional maturity of a
four-year-old
and um you know it's just a disaster and
um and
sadly i know him i mean i don't know him
but i mean i well there's a i'm an old
fart but i used to hang out with people
that did that and i i was always the
nerd that was forward-looking so i even
when those were my friends
in college or sitting around and that
guy's sitting beside you telling you the
same stupid stuff you know i'm always
looking at the guy even back then going
you you're it's not going to turn out
well for you
yeah i know
well and i think the
the sad thing is that the predictability
and the stability
of the quote unquote 401k or paid for
house all that right
that it feels boring and it's not
exciting and there's nothing um
it's just the only one that works that's
the only thing so i'm just saying too
i'm like it's just sad that we've gotten
to a culture that
things that do work and that do take
time and that delayed gratification all
that
like it's not
it's not celebrated like it's not you
know what i mean for some people for
some people i guess it fits into a
culture though where a show like that's
popular
oh yeah i mean because there's probably
culture is failing
[Music]
[Laughter]
that could be debatable the culture is
failing
the end is near
were these people when they came up with
the show concept
and then they then they go to chicago
what chicago just telling you what the
show's about i know i'm not endorsing
the lifestyle i'm just saying yeah
that's what it is you watched it all oh
every episode every episode
is the ramsey show